[Musique]
j'ai choisi le film demain un film nommé
sous le titre documentaire
j'en profite pour dire que ce film est
une preuve de plus que le documentaire
n'est pas du soufi de cinéma une seule
question ces images vous ont-elles
procuré une émotion oui oui pour ce film
une évidence une très belle émotion
si l'une des définitions du cinéma c'est
l'art de procurer d'illusions du
mouvement dans un film tous les
documentaires sont aussi des films en
mouvement et donc du cinéma nous savons
très bien faire des films violents ou
destructeur de notre planète est évacuée
soit disant par catharsis la violence
plus ou moins cachés qui tournait le
film demain vient annoncer la base d'un
jeu qui est tape dans le mille
oui un monde meilleur est à portée de
nous et tant mieux tant mieux parce que
si le moment est critique pour notre
humanité le moment est critique aussi
pour continuer à voir des films de
cinéma
donc je vous le recommande vivement à à
voir et à revoir ci n'évaluent et est
alors revoir sans modération et un très
vite demain dans les salles
[Musique]